hi there i'm back steve kaufman here i'm
back from my
20-day visit to
myanmar
vietnam and korea
and i want to talk about visiting the
visiting the country and learning the
language you often hear that in order to
learn a language you have to visit the
country and some people suggest that you
get a phrase book before going there and
then when you get there you'll be able
to use
these phrases
so i'll talk about my experience in
three countries
uh before going i to uh asia i did buy
uh vietnamese phrasebook with
uh some mp3 some files some audio or cd
which i listened to
i don't know how much time i put in a
couple of hours
um
and uh
but i went to myanmar first so
before uh i didn't do anything before
but when i went there i bought a little
book burmese okay
my experience is as follows
uh in burma for six days
seven days
i must have asked people
20 times how do you say hello how do you
say goodbye how do you say thank you
maybe please i mean those are really the
only words that you have a chance
of being able to say if you're there for
six days
i came out of it with
maybe two that i can remember mingalabar
which is
hello good day whatever
and um
jesuba i think jesus
which is thank you and tata is goodbye
that's all and i had to ask literally
over and over again i kept on forgetting
the only one that sticks after a while
is mingalabar because it's
it's
people say it to you all the time
because they're so friendly and i had to
have a little thing in my mind like ming
byla like in chinese to try and remember
mingalabar the point is
it's very difficult to pick up phrases
and looking in this phrase book
i mean it was hopeless to me how do you
say you know where is the or
not a chance unless the language is
pretty close to a language that you
already speak
so um stimulating uh to be there
but in terms of actually trying to say
something and and if they if even if i
were to say something so well like hello
that they started to speak to me in
their local language i would be lost so
looking at a few phrases before you go
there in the case of manbar useless
vietnam despite the fact that i studied
and i studied but i did listen and try
to get something again i ended up with
four or five words sincha which means
hello
uh
come on which means thank you
tampered which means goodbye
sin loy which means excuse me and i
think that's about it and that's after
seven days lots of effort i even bought
a dictionary so that i could perhaps
look up the word that i wanted to say
useless
uh i even also went and bought this book
to see how
the uh chinese characters are pronounced
in vietnamese i found that there aren't
nearly as many of those words in
vietnamese as there are in korean or
in japanese so the chinese characters
aren't that big of a help
so all i'm saying is going there
with the phrase book hoping to be able
to have any kind of meaningful
communication is a hopeless dream
all you can do it's not communication
it's about saying something in their
language which
it's like showing off and very often
they appreciate it so if you say
come on thank you in vietnamese people
appreciate it more than if you just said
thank you sometimes so it's not a major
way of learning the language uh korean
of course i've spent a lot of time in
korean find korean difficult despite all
the time that i spent on korean when i
first arrived in korea actually it was
difficult to swing into action right
away to try to use the language i went
to the subway
and there's a couldn't quite figure out
how to use their vending machine and i
asked one of the employees of the metro
system and he couldn't really understand
what i was saying i couldn't understand
what he was saying communication
zero
however
within two or three days of being there
of using it a little more here a little
more there all of my passive learning
got activated quite quickly and in our
meetup night where we had both koreans
and foreigners who spoke korean i was
able to speak quite a bit of korean and
then subsequently when i had to talk to
taxi drivers i had other situations
where i was dealing with people who
couldn't speak english
you know it was surprising how after a
day or two or three
the passive learning gets activated so i
sort of want to restate my conviction
that if you want to go and benefit from
visiting the country make sure that you
put in enough time we're talking six
months significant investment in the
language and even then when you get
there there will be a day or two or
three before you can activate it but
then
it's not just that you use it and hear
it more there's something about being in
an environment where that's the language
of communication so that it's no longer
just an academic exercise that seems to
that sort of atmospheric that
environment has the effect of of
activating your language so when you
have put enough time in your language by
all means visit the country it'll do
wonders for your language if you haven't
put enough
effort into it ahead of time
visiting the country it's still a
pleasant thing to do but you won't be
able to communicate and certainly
certainly you won't be able to rely on a
phrasebook so i went a bit longer than
my usual
three four minutes uh we'll see if we
can get a transcript done for this as
well thank you for listening bye for now